es ist der Auftritt von
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck bei
Maischberger wo er vergeblich versucht
eine Insolvenz zu erklären aber
vielleicht hat habe ich ja wirklich nur
so rumgeeiert weil ja noch nicht
offiziell ankündigen wollte konnte oder
durfte dass der Staat womöglich
Unternehmen in finanziellen
Schwierigkeiten wieder massiv
unterstützen muss wie zu corona-zeiten
das heißt Wirtschaftsminister nicht weiß
was eine Insolvenz ist das ist ja
eigentlich kaum vorstellbar ich meine
das weiß doch jedes Kind
das ist Bäcker Meyer Bäcker Meyer
verkauft in seiner Bäckerei täglich drei
Brötchen an seine Kunden Stückpreis 39
Cent von dem Geld das Bäcker Mayer
verdient kann er sehr gut leben außerdem
kann er die Zutaten für die Brötchen die
Miete für den Laden und seine
Energiekosten bezahlen doch jetzt kommt
das Problem der Backofen vom Bäcker
Meyer wird mit Gas geheizt Gas ist
aktuell sehr teuer um die gestiegenen
Gaskosten seines Backofens bezahlen zu
können muss Bäcker Meyer seine Brötchen
nun viel teurer verkaufen die Kunden die
normalerweise seine drei Brötchen
täglich kaufen finden den neuen
brötchenpreis aber viel zu hoch und
kaufen die Brötchen nicht mehr Bäcker
Meyer verdient also kein Geld mehr jetzt
hat Bäcker Meyer das nächste Problem
denn wenn Bäcker Meyer kein Geld
verdient kann er die Zutaten für die
Brötchen die für den Laden und seine
Energiekosten nicht mehr bezahlen den
Laden einfach zuzuschließen geht aber
auch nicht denn Miete muss trotzdem
bezahlt werden Bäcker Meyer kann also
seine Rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlen
wenn man seine Rechnungen nicht mehr
bezahlen kann ist man insolvent ganz
einfach
so einfach wäre es gewesen oder so
einfach hätte das laufen können
[Musik]